the White House has still not managed to
come up with a coherent and uniform line
to answer for Joe Biden's mishandling of
classified documents in fact green
Jean-Pierre is pretty much just walking
out bye Felicia because she can't answer
that turned out to be false are you
sorry about that I'll see you tomorrow
come talk to me the reporter you heard
the first part was a little bit cut off
was James Rosen who's a very serious
journalist he pointed out at least six
times that kjp had claimed that all
Biden classified documents were
accounted for and that turned out to be
false so she either was completely
ignorant or she was lying and so he said
hey you can't lie to us I know that your
job is to spin but you can't really lie
are you going to apologize she says bye